the right brill way good job
a little sunshine boy who just wanted
everyone to be happy
words from alby speakman's mum after a
tragic incident which took this boy's
life on saturday
the three-year-old was involved in a
collision with a tractor at his dad's
home in berry the latest casualty on a
farm
but this kind of tragedy is no stranger
to farmlands across britain
whether it's workers or family members
over the last five years at least 161
people have died on farms and the most
common cause is when someone is struck
by a moving vehicle and so the scale of
fatalities and accidents makes this
workplace the deadliest in the country
brian has first-hand experience of the
dangers in this industry earlier this
year he was sentenced for killing his
four-year-old nephew harry lee
i put him on the machine
as i had done in the past
and we drove out the yard on the lane
and into the field
and then
you know i turned around in the gun and
he was under the wheel and that's what
happened like i really saw so quick
how much do you miss not having him now
on the farm with you some lords
every day every day i miss him
he saw that i have to live with what
will happen to him
and
i'll do anything to bring him back
and it isn't just toddlers at risk data
released by the health and safety
regulator shows of the 25 deaths on
farms in the last year all but one were
adults farmers are pushed for time
they're trying to do a little bit more
than they should do they dependent on
the weather they're dependent on labour
they're dependent on finances so often
they push themselves a little bit too
far don't necessarily think ahead and
often the worst can happen
despite all of the education farming
continues to have the worst safety
record in the uk
indoman rashid sky news lancashire